all right so I already mentioned at the
top of the show in the u.s. we had this
long holiday weekend for Labor Day the
David Pakman show
was off we debuted a long-form episode
that we had previously produced on
healthcare so many Americans because of
the long holiday weekend didn't hear or
see the ridiculous and embarrassing Gong
Show of things that Donald Trump said
now unfortunately the rest of the world
didn't have a holiday weekend or at
least most countries didn't maybe
somebody did and thus they did see and
hear the absurdities that came out of
Donald Trump's mouth and out of his
Twitter account in the United States the
weekend saw the approach of hurricane
hurricane durian which is now a made
landfall the most powerful hurricane on
record at one point heading to Florida
South Carolina Georgia even parts of
North Carolina hurricane durian as of
last night had already killed at least
five people by the time you hear this
unfortunately but realistically that
number may be even higher and Donald
Trump says I've never even heard of a
category 5 storm before there have been
4 category 5 storms during his
presidency and of course his reaction to
the ones that did damage and caused
deaths in the past were disastrous and
atrocious reactions and responses check
this out what is he talking about
determined and resilient and we will
support each other and we will work very
hard to minimize whatever the effective
of what's coming at us we don't even
know what's coming at us all we know is
it's possibly the biggest I am not sure
I'm not sure that I've ever
the category 5 I knew it existed and
I've seen some categories worse you
don't even see them that much a category
5 is something that it's there when
you've already been criticized for your
terrible responses to prior hurricanes
when Puerto Rico was hit or why don't
remember where it was that he showed up
and shot paper towel rolls like
basketballs like some kind of game maybe
that was Florida maybe it was Puerto
Rico they're all kind of blending
together at this point because his
reaction to all of them was so horrible
and then you say who's even heard of
category 5 before you look even more
like you don't care when you say you've
never heard of an actual category 5
storm coming and there were four during
your presidency you seem like you don't
give you know what about the people that
are affected by the hurricanes Trump has
said this before by the way he said in
October of 2017 who's even heard of a
category 5 hurricane hitting land
hurricanes
Irma Maria and Michael were at different
points in that in the evolution of those
storms category 5 and then Donald Trump
creating even more chaos by saying
Alabama is going to get hit Alabama was
not under threat Donald Trump tweeting
quote in addition to Florida South
Carolina North Carolina Georgia and
Alabama will most likely be hit much
harder than anticipated looking like one
of the largest hurricanes ever already
category 5 be careful god bless everyone
and of course in Alabama
nobody from actual weather services had
said you're fine
I'm sorry nobody had said you're not
fine nobody has said you need to be
worried so Alabama immediately in a
panic officials right away having to say
hold on a second the president is wrong
you everything's okay in Alabama Alabama
you don't have to evacuate you're going
to be okay and it's stunning that in the
Trump presidency
scientists have been refuting Trump on
climate for the entirety of his
presidency and even when he was just
candidate Trump and now even on weather
which pi though I know a lot of people
on the right are probably saying David
what are you talking about climate and
weather or the
think no they're not and in fact that's
where a lot of confusion about climate
change comes from but now weather
services having to refute Donald Trump
on the subject of weather as well does
Donald Trump have any recollection of
the things that have happened during his
presidency truly I mean we talked
earlier about cognitive decline memory
issues etc does he not care to remember
or can he not remember is something
actually wrong with the guy's memory so
once again serious questions
increasingly being asked about would you
call this a narcissism issue is this a
memory issue is it a cognitive state
issue and we had I mean it's terrible
really we had yet another one of these
major red flag cognitive events with
Donald Trump over the weekend which I
talked about at the top of the show
another slurring and huffing and puffing
visibly confused moment from Donald
Trump
these are adding up there's multiple of
these per weekend and if you you know in
a sense the most benign explanation is
Trump is merely such a narcissist
focused only on himself that he just
doesn't care to remember all of the
other terrible storms that have happened
during his presidency in a sense it's
the most benign but it also is the one
indicative of the worst person possible
cognitive decline doesn't mean you're a
bad person memory issues don't mean
you're a bad person simply not caring
about other people is something where we
could say wow he really just doesn't
seem like a good guy which of course
would not come as a shock to anybody
who's been following this guy for the
last 10 or 20 years or however long he's
been around and notable in New York City
real estate